Could you possibly suggest a good allergy medicine for my cat allergies?
Yes, it's called cat no more, just get rid of the cat. I'm just kidding, just kidding.
Okay, so cat allergies, you know, they're on the market. There's over the culture
anti-histones, things that can help. And by the way, I have part section by book about anti-histones
with cancer, particularly breast cancer, they can be beneficial, meaning over the culture
into histones. But as far as nutrition to help with any external exposure type allergens,
whether it be environmental allergens from animal dandert or allergies from
pollen and environmental things like that, you have to look at the clear histamine scavenger.
We have three different main products for histamine issues because that's what allergies do,
they raise histamines. It would be the clear histamine scavenger is the broadest.
Then we have natural clear hist, which is some of just, I think it's four or five main things that
are clotted for airborne and environmental type allergies. And then we have histoclear, which is
DAO enzyme, which breaks down histamine in the gut. So that would be for mainly for food-based
allergies. So don't get that one. So I would start with clear histamine scavenger. I think that's
the broadest. That's what I would start with. I think that's your best bet.